technophobes c'est un court métrage que
j'ai écrit qui sont ces raconter
l'histoire d'un mec qui devient
allergique et la technologie
je viens d'un petit peu aidés sur sur
les structures rec la thématique de
nouvelles technologies ça revient très
souvent dans mes vidéos je me suis
vraiment dit un jour mais comment faire
sans et si pardon un mec tout seul ne
pouvait pas utiliser technologique il
n'y a pas de morale puisque à la fin qui
nous donne est allergique
imaginons dans un monde il ya un peu
plus d et technologies malheureusement
la technologie la technologie il ya eu
quatre jours et demi de tournage je
pense était le plus gros tournages que
j'ai pu faire en plus vraiment de 6
heures du matin jusqu'à parfois 23
heures dans des bonnes grosses journées
mais bon il y avait une équipe de
bouffer franchement c'était vraiment
super bien je dois retourner avec julien
j'adore tourner avec ludovic avec julien
pestel aussi tous ces gens là qui sont
tous cas dans cette vidéo donc ça
c'était vraiment chouette
et en plus l'équipe je connais très très
bien nous voilà chez mamie c'est comme
ça s'appelle le décor c'est la maison de
ma grand-mère pour savoir qu'on est à
une heure de paris
je sais même pas si c'est toujours la
france ici je crois qu'on a passé la
douane
c'est une blague et on va tourner du
coup avec avec claudette qui sera ma
grand mère claudette c'est quelqu'un qui
avait tourné assez souvent avec le
réalisateur
et quand je dis qu'il fallait un
grand-mère de comprendre que d'être
direct c'est un peu la mamie con ce
qu'on s'échange voilà hors contexte ça
fait bizarre comme ça mais je vais pas
spécialement des guest dans cette vidéo
mais je pouvais pas m'empêcher de
demander à des gens touchés qu'il
fallait une journaliste que je suis
demandé à laurence paraît que j'avais
rencontré pas si longtemps ensuite j'ai
demandé à maurice barthélémy s'ils
voulaient bien faire une apparition
moi je suis une grand grand fan de
maurice barthélémy n'est vraiment quand
j'étais gamin je regardais tous les
robins des bois tous ses films j'avais
même à plus quand j'avais quand j'avais
13 14 ans j'avais appelé tous les
maurice barthélémy qui avait dans
l'annuaire à paris pour essayer de
tomber sur lui
c'est pas tomber sur lui mais bien
évidemment dix ans plus tard j'ai pu le
rencontrer je vais vous montrer ça le
script et 3 ça chouette il a bien voulu
faire du coup le médecin et c'était très
dur de garder son sérieux sans exploser
de rire entre encore donne ton oreille
alors c'est une pâle tournage pour
commencer à réaliser un rêve de gosse
qui ait pu nous tirer avec une personne
âgée tout plaisir est pour moi non c'est
pas ça m'a fait super moi je suis
cyprien depuis que j'ai 8 ans l'ag mais
tout est filmé et j'ai même assisté à la
naissance et franchement ça touche dans
le script avait écrit julien essaye d
objets sur sur arthur c'était il y avait
juste écrit ça et ensuite il se rend
compte qu'il devient allergique à
technologie est pris avec les collines
mais on a du coup on s'est retrouvés
signalement à 40 minutes de rushes de
julien qui teste des objets sur moi une
banane un truc chiant avec cette affaire
on your t'as pas gagné au pur
le seul regret que j'ai eu c'est on l'a
tourné une séquence de nuit dans mon
appart et j'ai oublié d'enlever mes
lunettes
le personnage d'arthur ne porte pas de
lunettes c'était la seule différence
avec moi c'est le genre et mes lunettes
comme tout le monde à l'habitude de voir
des lunettes ils sont pas tilté qu'il
fallait que je les enlève
on a tourné et là on rend les clés du
décor et là je me rends compte qu'en
fait je me les enlever je fais tout pour
retourner dans mon sens qu'on fait non
on n'a plus le décor c'est terminé du
coup voilà mon personnage
les problèmes de vue à un moment et là
on est au mixage
donc c'est pas compliqué sur le tournage
y avait des micros partout donc en fait
la technique de mixage c'est de tout
réunir essayer demain qu'on entende tour
et qu'on comprenne
on vous laisse et de comme dans les
films classiques essayer d'avoir un
thème récurrent une sorte de leitmotiv
qui revient sur tous les faits ça va
être des deux thouet c'est un peu faim
qu'ils quand j'ai pas de jets pas de
contrainte je sais pas où aller
là tu as une contrainte est en fait par
la contrainte tu pousses sa créativité
c'est fou de voir autant de gens
s'investir comme ça à plein de niveaux
sur
sur la une idée qui a germé dans
l'esprit dans ses chouettes et je pense
en refaire des cousines